and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and terrorism
pursuant to section 4a of house
resolution 829 no organization or
legislative business will be conducted
on this day the chair will address the
germ the chamber
today one year ago the capital and those
who work within it were targeted in a
violent insurrection that sought to
undermine democracy
as we acknowledge the horror of that day
we honor the heroism of so many
particularly u.s capitol police
institutional staff floor leadership
committee and member staff
we had a session this morning
where we could say thank you to many of
them
unfortunately covet did not enable us to
have the full house we will have another
time when the attending physician allows
but as we acknowledge the horror of that
day in the face of extreme danger they
all risked
their safety for our democracy by
protecting the capital complex members
staff press etc
press within
safeguarding the ballots in those
mahogany boxes
to validate the election and ensuring
that congress could accomplish our
purpose and our honor honor our duty to
the constitution and to our country
that day and the days after
they were the defenders of our democracy
and their courage and patriotism
remain an inspiration
because of them
congress was able
to defeat the insurrection to return to
the capitol that same night to ensure
that the peaceful transfer of power took
place because of them
and our members the insurrection field
one year later this sacred space where
members legislate children learn
visitors are welcomed was defiled and
damaged we know that as we reflect on
that darkest day we remember that the
insurrection sought not only to attack
the building
but to undermine democracy itself
when the violent assault was made on the
capitol its purpose was to thwart
congress's constitutional duty to
validate the electoral count and to
ensure the peaceful transfer of power
but the assault did not deter us from
our duty i say again in this capital a
symbol of democracy to the world that
evening the congress because of the
courage of all the view rose to honor
oath and protect our democracy
we did so honoring the words of
president lincoln during the civil war
fellow citizens he said we cannot escape
history
we will be remembered in spite of
ourselves
no personal ins significance or
insignificance
can spare us one or another
we hold the power
therefore we bear the responsibility
lincoln said
today we accept responsibility as
daunting and demanding as any that
previous generations of leadership have
faced
since the january sixth inspiration
there have been continued assaults on
our democracy undermining the sanctity
of the vote and the integrity of our
elections which are the basis of our
democracy
let us be true to the vision of our
founders who brilliantly established our
democracy and made it a model for the
world
let us honor the sacrifice of our men
and women in uniform who protect that
freedom with their lives
and let us remember the words of another
president our patriarch
george president george washington
when he delivered the constitution
to the congress he said this
he said this constitution represents the
creation of a government which would
allow for the continuation of rigorous
debate
but relies upon the common sense and
good faith of the american people to
find the better angels of our nature
as we proceed let us find our common
ground reach our nation's heights with
liberty and justice for all remembering
the words of our great patriarch and in
the spirit that our
chaplain referenced of president lincoln
with malice toward none with charity
toward all
let us acknowledge today
as i conclude i want to acknowledge
our fallen heroes of that day
u.s capitol police officer brian siknik
u.s capitol police officer howard living
good
metropolitan officer jeffrey smith
u.s capitol police officer billy evans
of a later assault
now i ask all members to rise for a
moment of silence in their memory
thank you
pursuant to section 11b of house
resolution 188 the house stands
adjourned until 6 30 pm on monday
january 10
you